alors bruno podalydès bonjour bonjour
merci d'être là à la veille de la sortie
de votre film comme un avion qui sort le
10 juin
on a la chance de vous avoir parce que
vous êtes versaillais c'est ça notre
lien avec les yvelines
vous êtes né à versailles je crois oui
et vous êtes resté jusqu'à quand
traitance et être bien louis pinton
d'accord et déjà à l'époque vous aviez
envie de faire du cinéma
non je suis jamais dit je ferai du
cinéma j'y suis arrivé en faisant en
fait mon premier film je pensais pas
qu'ils marcheraient vers ça rime bouche
louis david a marché j'ai continué à
faire du cinéma
d'accord d'ailleurs il ya d'ailleurs une
trilogie oui qui lie la voilà sur
également verser gauche versailles rive
droite version tulle et versailles
chantiers voilà après on a eu ma dose
film ailleurs là on est un peu loin de
versailles avec comme un avion
oui on est dans l'yonne à celle saint
cloud s'il sort les yvelines l'epic la
celle saint cloud le héros oui c'est
vrai on habite à celle cinq lots comme à
john baird s'était aussi tourné à
châteauroux les connais pas alors voilà
mais bon c'est loin comme un petit à
petit on s'est toujours les yeux vides
c'est toujours les yvelines oui moi j'ai
l'impression que ce qu'on va dire vite
fait 103 côté michel le héros que vous
jouez donc par pour une aventure
qui finalement ne va pas être très
longue mais qui va quand même être une
aventure et qui va commander mon âme
sans que ça se passe hors du temps que
le temps s'est arrêté
on est presque sur une autre planète et
c'est ça la voiture pour vous changer de
monde non aventure ça peut être dans
notre propre monde sinon il va dans son
propre pays il va pas aux antilles oui
oui on a quand même l'impression qu'il
est complètement ailleurs et put notion
de temps oui parce qu'en fait ils
rentrent dans un autre temps dans une
autre durée qui est sec et le rythme de
la rivière j'ai un peu vrai il veut être
dépaysé il venu changer de pays dans son
propre pays c'est la région parisienne
et ouais mais en fait ils y accèdent un
espèce de d'espace-temps il a posé que
huit jours de congés
oui c'est même aller loin mais si oui
c'est on peut réussir à huit jours de
congés si effectivement on change
complètement le rythme de rythme et de
l'entourage parce que les tanks sur une
bande de frappadingue ses plaisirs des
inconnus avec qui sympathisent très vite
d'ailleurs on retrouve jean noël beauté
oui je m'essaie d'une mosquée à côté ça
y est voilà qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
dans chacun de vos films finalement
autres actions si oui bien sûr et deux
oui c'est un essai très grand acteur
pour moi expire qui sont très drôles et
pour plus d amis dans la vie
pourquoi ce coup mais bien sûr le
plaisir se partagent aussi comme ça et
vous voit pour la première fois beaucoup
et l'écran puisque vous tenez premiers
rôles le rôle de michelle est ce que
c'est ce que vous vous livrez encore
plus ce n'est pas spécialement je suis
forcément je pense que quand on joue à
fortiori un premier rôle ya des tas de
choses qui nous échappent
des gestes des regards fin je vois là je
suis pas une machine tout non contrôle
donc je sais qu'il ya des choses
personnelles que je n'ai pas voulu
qu'ils sont dans le cygne et vous l'avez
vu ça après au montage oui parfois on
réalise des petits des petites choses
c'est pas un petit de lâcher prise
oui oui toute façon on est très
personnelle dès qu'on parle de choses
qu'on aime d'accord du québec que j'aime
beaucoup c'est une vraie passion
gaillac ah oui entre autres aux décors
et lorsque est rigolo c'est qu'au début
le personnage il est une autre passion
c'est à celle de l'aviation oui sans
avoir vraiment volé non ils cherchent
pas à voler cherche pas pris l'avion en
soit voilà qu'on compte mais les
voitures sauf heures de course auto bien
sûr et est donc on écoute on rentre dans
leur appartement on voit tout est décoré
en fonction de sa passion lui fête son
anniversaire on lui offre quelque chose
qui correspond avec l'aviation et on a
des bases au bout d'un moment
presque trop cette passion et elle est
trop partager elle s'étend exactement ce
que c'est ce que vous vous dites pas
trop partager sa passion
il faut garder en ses rêves un peu
secret et ses patients un peu secrète
sinon savez les gens qui collectionnent
et vend des petites grenouilles qui
torture après tout les amis l'europe de
tito ricardo ils ont créé leur
appartient plus à leurs fins et plus on
est oui c'est il faut je crois que
quelqu'un parte et petits jardins
secrets mais
c'est donc vous donc d'ailleurs alors
ils changent de passion il se met au
kayak qui s'entraînent sur son toit oui
voilà
est ce qu'il a vraiment envie de partir
ou pas on se demande si c'est pas comme
l'avion finalement ce que ça lui suffit
pas oui c'est même pas qu'il change de
patience et qui prolonge cette passion
elle accouche de duncan yake pas des
fois d'un petit bimoteur non gagnant
sera air l'avion sans zèle voilà mais
continue à voler son kayak en fait en
imagination d histoire au nez en voilà
et donc grâce à son épouse rachel elle
le pousse on apprend presque elle croit
plus en son rêve que lui oui et du coup
elle le pousse à agir la distinction
royale lui se contenterait de de rêver
encore et elle
lmc me marque d'amour c'est comme si
bien c'est que 64 qui permettent à l'eau
de s'épanouir de martyrs peut-être
qu'elle a envie qu'il parte aussi où
c'est possible et ça c'est bien de 200
tonnes et de liberté beaucoup plus oui
d'accord et je me demandais donc il a il
a la cinquantaine est ce que c'est ce
besoin de s'échapper cesser la crise de
la cinquantaine tout bêtement de faire
un break
tel est d'ailleurs moi je pense pas que
ce soit spécifique à l'âge cette envie
de partir s'octroyer une parenthèse vous
un petit domaine personnel je pense
qu'on peut se désirent plus ce que t'es
con 10 50 ans dit crise enfin moody's
crise à 40 81 t'est n'ont pas l'impact
est en fait les dents c'est l'idée de
ses pattes enfuir ce qui vit que
d'accéder à d'autres horizons
ouais et vous alors votre passion
secrète le secret de l'addip
les images qui font ce qui est chaque
fois que j'expose je parlais pas de mon
goût pour le kayak jusque là j'aime
faire un film et je vous disais mais
qu'est ce qui est bien c'est que je
pense que je vais continuer en fait des
photos de la page du quiz avec avaya
verdez way et la longue je vous
rencontre parfois mon pari d'un adieu
berthe j'ai parlé de la magie parce que
j'aime beaucoup ce que je voulais dire
où il a aussi un petit tour de magie
dans votre film c'est un petit clin
d'oeil c'est à dire qu'il a eu d'autres
patients avant et ukulélé il a eu
d'autres il vit comme ça de patients
pression après on peut continuer on peut
considérer sa vie comme ça aux roannais
hopper des patients pour lesquels sa
marque d'autres temps ça c'est pas cool
biz et philippe roques ça c'est l'époque
c'était d'accord et à josé écouté à la
radio du doubs sur france inter vous
parliez de dire aller s'était bien gardé
un regard d'enfant quand on était
réalisateur et vous disiez le fait
d'avoir un regard d'enfant permettait de
voir les choses de façon plus conceptuel
oui j'ai entendu ça mais je croirais ce
que ça veut dire
je vous renvoie vos petits
de l'imaginer du père castor par exemple
20 on dit qu'une auto une voiture un
avion une carotte lapin et c'est l'idée
qu'on se fait du lapin l'idée qu'on se
fait de l'avion c'est très conceptuel
c'est le concept de l'avion le concept
unique
c'est après 2 quand on grandit on se
rend compte qu'un plein de lapin
différents et des avions de toutes
sortes on et images simples sur lesquels
on se construit comme ça rien ne pas
perdre de vue cette idée c'est quoi un
avion c'est quoi une fusée l image
étalon de la viande c'est le concept de
l'avion il ya pas un prêtre en pleine
forme différente mais on garde
la première fois comme on a regardé
comme on l'a vu
oui mais voilà comme il s'est inscrit
dans nos imaginaires ce fameux michel
cotis par fo son aventure en kayak
il est sûr suréquipés enfin voilà le
truc qui fait treize équipes et pas sûr
non il est suffisamment équipées oui
très matos et vous êtes comme ça dans la
vie
hamatos bas durant fait quand on est
ambitieux les gens s'équipent ça permet
des v6 geffroy aussi j'ai chaud donc on
couvre un peu tous les invités et puis
après on se rencontre souvent au move en
vie dans sa valise qu'on s'est servi de
la moitié des vêtements ou des objets
pour les amener à oui ça c'est un truc
comique qui comme un tout le monde et
vous ça vous permet de mettre des objets
incroyables comme vous aimez bien faire
existe vraiment
il est vrai qu'il existe vraiment mais
sam a dénoncé les jeux supporter le
rythme afrique en sommet à la fin du
film est quand même un petit clin d'oeil
à versailles yalaoui exelmans pourquoi
là avec tellement c'est comme ça au
guidon et la promotion souvient oui
c'est moins pana que la rue galilée nude
maréchal bien je sais même pas qui
exhale mance et sinon je voulais vous
demander à partir de quel moment on
passe à un autre film dans sa tête quand
est ce qu'on se dit tiens j'ai des idées
ça va comment ça ce qu'on sait que tu as
lease
oui j'ai belges et les illettrés tôt par
contre j'ai vraiment passé dans deux
jours un prochain film
j'attends depuis la sorte mercredi et
jeudi
déjà bah oui celui-là sera remis au
public et n'est plus la charge et je
vais me concentrer sur le suivant mais
ils sortent ou et j'ai toujours
plusieurs projets
qui grandissent mais quand vous noté des
idées oui je vois là je préside et
aubade au jour le jour en cours en
voyant dans la vie de tous les jours
voilà 21 histoire oui moi mon espoir du
temps aussi parce que c'est celle ci
voulait j'ai la chance que tout ce que
je fais nourri mon travail sur un cinéma
ça peut être pour le boulot parce que
j'aurais été le rédacteur
tout ce que je fais peut nourrir mon
travail on vous travaillez plus
d'entrées tout le temps j'ai voulu voilà
j'ai pas eue mardi
jadis très irrégulière simple et bien on
écarte ou en finir
ce que
depuis chaque film c'est un vente je
leur demande pardon
comment celui là est née je serais
incapable de dire c'est trop vieux ce
n'est pas non j'ai pas eu la foudre est
tombée du ciel ça vient ça mûrit
tout doucement d'accord cette fois ci
votre frère denis n'a pas participé à
l'écriture non 2000 il a écrit avec moi
à tube hey oui c'est ça la liberté
oléron d'accord qu'est-ce que sept films
où vous avez le sentiment de vous livrer
le plus avec liberté oléron d'être le
plus dans la team
forcément ce qu'on veut en libye par
exemple le mi5 chambre ajourne le fait
parler des romans populaires des livres
de gaston leroux de la magie j'ai jeu
j'y mettais beaucoup de moi même parce
que là je parlais justement des familles
jardin secret on est toujours en
racontant sa vie qu'on est plus
personnelle ni en se montrant gros plans
film bat pas forcément parce que je me
sentais un acteur je dis pas que michel
c'est moi très bien bah écoutez bruno un
grand merci
et puis rester pour ce beau film
encore un beau film parenthèse enchantée
qui fait réveiller et qu'on a très envie
de revoir quand on l'a vu une fois c'est
chouette merci merci